say hello everybody hope everybody's
ready for this session because I am Gary
is doing I'm doing well how are you
great
hello Hong Kong hello Hong Kong now
that's the spirit yes okay before we
start maybe maybe I'm going to start a
little bit there's going to be a Q&A
session here so please get ready with
your questions and then you can ask Gary
straight away but before we start if I
see a lot of your videos and all that
and you talked a lot about startups
right and there's so many startups right
here at Rice and they rise and they fall
and their rise and they fall how many
times did you rise and fall all the way
through your own experience well as an
entrepreneur I think I rise and fall on
a daily basis on a micro on a macro I
haven't had too many falls in the
companies that I've run because to be
very frank I was born in the Soviet
Union I'm an immigrant and I am NOT a
tech entrepreneur that thinks about
funding and customer acquisition and
metrics that have nothing to do with
running a business the businesses that
I've run have been a wine-shop ecommerce
business and a digital agency neither
had funding the first was a family
business the second I started by getting
a client vaynermedia is seven years old
I've grown it from 0 to 125 million
dollars in revenue and we never raised
the dollar I just run a business you
know a business one where you make more
money than you spend right and it's
about having customers so I haven't had
Falls because I haven't put myself in
the position to be a unicorn or go out
of business
I've been tried and true build actual
businesses on a micro I make [ __ ]
mistakes daily and I think that that is
just part of the game and it's all right
to make that kind of mistake and not
getting back up yeah I think the biggest
reason I believe we're living through
fake
tripping oars and a huge influx of fake
entrepreneurship is because you have to
love to lead you have to like to have
the chip on your shoulder The Scarlet
Letter if you're a purebred entrepreneur
I prefer prefer to be underestimated I
would argue for all my self-promotion
and me being out there I speak if you
know my spiel a lot more about my hard
work than my smarts
I rarely talk about being smart like you
know I let my actions speak to my
smartness on proper investments or
predicting where the world's going or
auditing where the world is properly but
I like losing I like I mean I left the
wine business because I won I will leave
the agency landscape eventually to now
that vein are starting to become a
player it's not as fun I like when
people don't you know one of the reasons
I'm so excited about getting into the
Asian market with my content with
Boehner medium with my investing is I'm
far less of an entity in this part of
the world
I'm underestimated that's more
interesting to me I I like getting
punched in the mouth
I hope well that that requires lots of
patience a hundred percent 100 percent
right and I see a lot of entrepreneurs
when they start they think maybe within
like three months to six months they're
gonna they're going to achieve lots of
money and goals and everything it
requires a little way longer than that
right the patient itself
yeah we're also I want to remind
everybody here this has been an
unbelievable of era of unbelievable
amounts of money poured into the
ecosystem so for the last seven to eight
years almost nine years now we've been
on the rebound of global economic issues
and obviously if you're talking about
mainland China there was no rebound it's
just been growth so one of the things
that's fascinating to me is that a lot
of the entrepreneurs that are navigating
right now are
navigating under the greatest time to
build businesses maybe in the history of
all time if you look at the financial
structure so the lack of patience
the lack of actually having you know
when I think about all the startups here
there are a few few that are actually
profitable they're all burning listen
let me let me give you let me give you a
fun little statement Hong Kong it
doesn't take a [ __ ] hero to lose
money every month so hoping that anybody
can do that you're not special so I
think that 98% of them will make it to
the other side they'll never build
something that sustains itself
there'll be economic slowdown everybody
will wake up and realize they're far
better off to take their money and put
it into public markets than into this
horseshit and this great golden era will
burn and everybody here will go work for
at a bank and the ones that don't when
they hear me say that and they go [ __ ]
you Gary if they can back it up and
execute they'll win and that's the game
what's amazing amazing about being part
of the entrepreneurial ecosystem is its
meritocracy winners win and losing
players lose it's fun I love that about
this game when I lose I say that I
deserve it hmm I think I deserve it I
made a mistake I was wrong about the
market I was wrong about a person I was
wrong I never think it was your fault or
this fault or TechCrunch wrote the wrong
thing or like I lost you on it right
of course it's I mean the quickest way
for me to judge somebody who I know is
not going to win long term is their
ability to blame others
hmmm interesting that's very interesting
I'm pretty sure everybody here wants to
ask lots of questions to Gary but before
we go there and how are we doing that do
you guys have runners yet are they
lining up they're lining others
one more question about planet off the
apps yes oh what's the background about
that I'm pretty sure everybody wants to
know Apple sent me an email and said you
want to be on a show that we're going to
put in 131 countries with will I am
Jessica Alba and Gwyneth Paltrow and I
said [ __ ] yes isn't that amazing okay
anybody want to ask question to Gary
hi Harry how are you hey I just want to
say that you don't have you don't get
enough credit for being very present and
100% whenever your eyes like answering
questions to us and met respect for that
so you're you're my [ __ ] rock star so
my question is this um in business
anything can happen right yes so god
forbid but if if there's a major
catastrophe that's happening to
vaynermedia can you please tell us
probably three or five things that you
do to readjust your clouds and dirt and
the strategic things that you would do
let me ask you a question
it will bring values there's three
catastrophes in the way that I think
about it there's real life which I would
put into the category of health issues
for me or the people I most love
there's outside internal forces that
could be a catastrophe which means
business partners or investors and then
there's number three out can you let her
hold the mic for a second can you get it
back thank you
and then there's number three there's
internal it was under your watch your or
your employees moves caused the
catastrophe which one are you asking I
mean the things like lawsuits
scandals or you know like what militia
allies have you know like I understand
can follow all kinds of things like that
which is yes you could probably prevent
it but or probably see it or something
like that but things like this happen
here you can't you know so to me you
know for some of you that know that I
write books I wrote a book called Jab
Jab Jab right hook it was around content
but I but it was funny I wrote that
title for myself a little bit as an
inside joke to myself I've never said
this out loud
d-roc you don't even know this it's and
some of you've heard me say this but
this is why I titled it I think being an
entrepreneur and a CEO is a
counter-puncher I don't think it's
strategy up front you know let's use
football and I mean not American
football soccer as I call it football I
think being a CEO is more about the
coach that is losing three to zero and
have time and knows what to do to win
four to three then being the coach that
spends the whole week or two weeks
getting ready to be winning 3-0 so to
answer your question I'm mentally
prepared for all catastrophes at all
times including the ones that I'm most
scared of which is the health and
well-being of myself and my family you
have no choice
if your [ __ ] plane disappears out of
the air or land somewhere you have no
choice like this thought that you're in
control of anything is ludicrous what
you're in control of is your mental
status to when that happens so for me I
think I'm a firefighter
I literally sit in my little place and
I'm waiting for it to go real real like
when I get off here's a perfect one when
I get off stage right here right now
right now I'm captive right now I'm
paying attention for another 30 to 51
I'll say hello to a little bit more 10
more minutes I will then walk back there
and I will open my phone and I will have
seven headaches that takes a certain
level of mentality that a lot of people
don't have it's a lot of fun at first
when you have an idea and somehow
miraculously your ideas worth four
million dollars and people give you a
million dollars for you to go and do it
that's when you celebrate and you go out
and everybody thinks you're a hero it's
the next day when [ __ ] starts getting
ugly and I've got good news for you how
many people here are parents raise your
hand perfect it's the same [ __ ] the
second that [ __ ] kid is born you're
on the clock and you're worried for the
rest of your life and that's what a
business is it's I never feel easy hmm
ever
I don't feel easy right this second I
don't feel easy tomorrow
I don't feel easy for the rest of my
life because it's all on my shoulders
and so how do I handle it easy because
I'm built for it yes thanks
awesome so basically we're talking about
you know when you have fears you just
don't give a [ __ ] about it just go for
it and you listen everybody's I'm
petrified of my mother's health like
petrified so I have fear
I just think life's about alternatives
life's like I don't give a [ __ ] when
people talk to me about theory it's a
binary like when when your spouse gets
terminally ill theory doesn't matter you
have to navigate when you lose your
biggest clients that represent how many
people here have businesses that have
very large clients that represent big
portions of their business raise your
hands how many people here have a client
that represents more than 50% of their
business raise your hand I mean that's
[ __ ] scary for these eleven people
like their business is suck my god ain't
nothing like one more time for the 11 of
you I want to give you a piece of ice
you need to like tomorrow like you
should leave this talk right now leave
and start citing other customers because
that's scary like who wants to be that
vulnerable to something that they don't
control you know so for me like there's
there's just things that you can't
control if the 11 of them lose that
client tomorrow because the
decision-maker that is their client goes
to a different company and the new one
doesn't like them or that or has a
sister that has a similar business
they're in panic mode they better adjust
and so you know you know me people hears
businesses rely on somebody that is not
them it is scary how many people's
businesses hear that the most important
person to the business is not them that
it's a salesperson that it's a technical
leads co-founder it's somebody else that
is scary and yeah so there's a lot of
things we don't control when we build
our businesses the market don't even
listen I'm a boy that's born in Soviet
Russia you start thinking about markets
where you have to be nice with the
families that run the country [ __ ] right
there's a lot of things we don't talk
about
that make it scary which is why I don't
like the current state of
entrepreneurship in the world because it
seems very party and popular and cool
and it is literally everything button I
started my daily vlogs yes I like
attention and I want selfies but much
more because I want people to see how
hard it really is how long every day is
if you really want to be successful and
so I'm scared of everything which
actually ironically means I'm scared of
nothing right that he understands yeah I
got a click me got it I know it's a
funny little statement but by accepting
yes fear of everything it kind of makes
me numb and makes me not fear of
anything anything in that's awesome more
questions guys that was interesting yeah
I never said that before to write it on
the quotes now on your ancestor gonna be
on my internet tomorrow
hey hey Gary big fan thank you uh we run
a home-based senior care company in
mainland China home base got it
so we do we train caregivers and they go
to the home gives love addresses keep
people at home where they want to be
understood our challenge our biggest
struggle is selling the intangible and a
still very tangible focused customer
base especially in mainland China so
we're having a hard time helping the
consumer to understand what where
there's value in an intangible business
where it's mostly the decision makers
the the children they're providing a
service for their for their parents as
they're not really interacting with on a
daily basis any advice that you would
have what are you trying to accomplish
creating a wider net took more customer
acquisition yeah we're our biggest
struggles lead generation so we're we're
in other countries and have done quite
well in other other markets and one
touch more what has worked there in
those other markets I in the rest of the
world we sell quality care so people
understand that there's a variable right
there even though black and white it
looks the same they understand the
nuances that make you eight dollars
versus somebody else that's
for exactly so that's right whereas the
mainland China that variable hasn't
existed right so we're selling time and
freedom convene right in China not
necessarily quality um why do you think
that's happening people in China hate
their parents stop kidding I'm kidding
no I think there's some aspect of that
that you think it's supply and demand of
competitive landscape I think partly
there's a there's an informal caregiver
that already lives in the home where you
have that in Hong Kong and Singapore in
China so they already have a very low
rect that's exactly right
alternative so once you know look I'd
have to dig deeper to give you probably
the best advice but I'm going to give
you something that will work for
everybody and already I see enough
nuances in your question that will make
this valuable the biggest mistake that
companies make is they fight the market
right so for me I would argue to take a
step back and remodel it to drive down
the costs even more not the other way
around I'd much rather spend all my time
understanding the nuances and overhead
of my business to drive the cost down
instead of trying to culturally commence
people that they need to pay the Vig of
my brand versus the alternative
it is a fundamental important business
practice that a lot of companies lose on
especially in the exact scenario that
you have which is when the model is
working in other places this is why
people lose in new markets all the time
because they try to play the same
blueprint and what they think is it's a
marketing nuance
I've often find that it's a product
nuanced excellent thing you got it thank
you
more questions
hey Gary Scott here I'm big fan one
thing I knew talk a lot about
documenting yeah than you do like it's a
great way to produce content how do you
keep it so fresh because you guy I mean
you've got that you've got someone
following you around doing daily be
every doing daily be every day how do
you make sure that you keep your content
fresh you keep your narrative new and
keep your audience engaged well I'm
super [ __ ] interesting I'm a tender
ego look I think I think what's worked
for me is that I understand things are
tried and true there are only certain
ways we can communicate with each other
the written word video audio so what
I've done I think well is created a
framework the vlog d-roc where you at
let's hear for d-roc it's a really
important thing we did by having the
blog like the thing I just said about
fear I'm booking documenting everything
I do that's the first time I've ever
said that now what happens back home is
it'll probably make the vlog this will
this whole day of eight hours 12 hours
15 hours of filming becomes as you know
a 17 minute piece of something yeah it's
the other content that grooms from it
the vlog is the framework but all the
quotes on Instagram the articles on
medium the podcast will expand a Colin
for my team in seven days inevitably is
going to ask me 13 questions over a
phone call of what I meant about fearing
everything and then fearing nothing so
the way I've kept it fresh is by
documenting everything we're stumbling
into things on a daily basis that we've
never said or never interacted before so
I love Q&A so much it's forcing new [ __ ]
out of me and then I'm creating so you
literally read a medium post in nine
days because off a question just now I
randomly said that so we've created a I
am a human media company and the pillar
of my media the anchor
gram is the blog and all the ancillary
supporting content programs come from
the mothership got it sorry I sell
sawdust right the byproduct is I'm
cutting this wood but the sawdust one
day somebody in the world looked at all
the sawdust all the stuff that fell from
cutting wood and said [ __ ] I'm going to
sell that so for smaller businesses you
would suggest for them to actually
create their content based on the
conversations they're having with their
customers if they want to paint a
narrative of a business personality
environment okay
right you know to be it works hand in
hand you know some businesses dollars
but Wine Library would have worked that
way if I was documenting when I ran a
wine store when sales people were coming
in and tasting me online that could have
been the ancillary creative so I think
you have to make sure the creative
matches the strategy of the business
that you're running I at that time
wouldn't have wanted to be a business
thought leader I would have just wanted
people to be obsessed with my wine
tasting skills and selling skills so the
blog or the quotes would have been more
about me tasting a wine that I didn't
even decide to buy for Wine Library but
I was giving you guys value by reviewing
this champagne that you could have
bought elsewhere I would have brought
you value that would have impacted me
got it
sawdust still related to that question
though you are house men house bran have
digital experiment right what's the tip
for people actually want entrepreneurs
wants to do business but they are their
own brand like their own name is their
own brand not a company everybody is
their own brand today now there's a lot
of people that are introverted there's a
lot of people that are overly humble
there's a lot of people that are private
you don't need to expand on your brand
but guys we're just using the word
personal brand for a word we used for a
long time
it's called reputation writing like I
don't care what you call it to make it
fancy
we have traded on reputation from the
beginning of mankind oh the person in
the other town
cut is a better butcher than the one
that I have I'll go there right like
we've traded on reputation forever the
fact that we now live in an era where
you can expand on that to the scale that
we have never seen my ability to build
my personal brand my reputation in
Indonesia or Australia or Greece from
the confines of my home in New York City
with a very small spend on Facebook or
with some KO Elle's in the marketplace
is remarkable in an unparallel an
all-time iconic and grossly underpriced
right now you know it's harder to be
combined you in Amazon today it was a
lot easier in 1999 this is a very
special moment in time and most people
are wasting it because they're debating
if it's a good idea right moving on sir
I think he really wants to ask question
hahaha you were there before I saw you
thank you so much Gary this is Miuccia
born in Romania living in Toronto Canada
in Hong Kong for the week the first
thing on your tutor bio is a large
family man yeah family first
how do you balance family and
entrepreneurship by first making myself
happy
thank you well that's a very short but
very important and and he and to his
credit he understood very very quickly I
could see it even in his eyes but I'll
expand on it for everybody if you are
not happy it will all break yes just
appeasing what is it ever politically
correct right now in work-life balance
or your parents the biggest thing I tell
kids of why they should fight their
parents is it's a lot better to fight
your parents at 19 20 or 21 then to hate
them at 42 it is it's practical this is
not emotional the amount of people that
resent their parents to go becoming a
lawyer and a doctor and blame
them for the rest of their lives and
then have no relationship with them for
45 years or underlying ly quietly on the
low don't have a good relationship with
them as enormous lehigh you're much
better to battle it out in your 20s you
just are it's smarter hmm it's the same
way I think about work-life balance look
as you know if you follow me at all I
don't show any part of my family which
makes it eat and I work a lot which then
makes it seem like I spend no time with
them but every weekend you won't see me
in August at all you won't feel it
because I know how to create content
like a media company but I will be
around right and so you know I'm I'm
seven weeks vacation with my family I'm
with my family every weekend it just
doesn't feel like that because I figured
out how to create and distribute at a
scale that most human beings haven't
figured out yet right but but I always
have to start with me the greatest way
to be selfless is to be selfish that's
really good it's interesting right it's
like and it's becoming the theme of this
conversation if you look at me
I pull from very opposite direction
right I'm fearless in my overwhelming
fear right I'm selfless in my
overwhelming need to be selfish I adore
your admiration so much I read your
Instagram post yesterday you posted and
you wrote six or seven sentences and I
read every [ __ ] word I needed so much
mainly because my mom coddled me and
loved me so much that I'm trying to the
places that I'm such a good guy because
I need the admiration so my selflessness
comes from that selfishness you know I'm
I you know it just makes sense the
balance comes in the extreme opposite
pulling right I really don't give a [ __ ]
with anybody in here thinks of me zero
hmm i massively care what every single
person in here thinks of me
it's those pulling it's in that strength
macro patients I'm the most patient I'm
a termini as a company on building I'm
spent guys stick with me here I'm
spending ten years of the best years of
my life to build an agency that I have
no interest in building I just want to
build it as a framework for all my
future behavior in my 50s and 60s and
70s I'm giving up ten years I tell kids
that patients littering up patients for
three years to build the company they
want to build and sell yeah I after
already making tens of millions of
dollars and building a [ __ ] [ __ ]
agency business and have clients for ten
years to be a framework for all my
future buying businesses and running
them through the Vayner machine right
macro patience but on a daily basis I'm
faster than all of you micro speed 17
hours a day programmed 24/7 right
programs every second program fast fast
is [ __ ] I will absolutely positively
do more today than most people do in a
week for their business in one day on a
daily basis but on a macro it's a
[ __ ] 40-year platform pulling from
opposite directions balanced right
awesome don't forget to be happy guys
that's like the most important thing
we're going over there unhappy and
unhappy at the same times is that that's
the balance so like you write like you
know like it's just so funny right yes
like like if you know what you're doing
I you know what it really comes down to
it comes down to a hard core
self-awareness yes
do you really know why you're doing it
you actually know what you're trying to
accomplish
like what each are you trying to scratch
if it's money I've got great news
that's the easiest part of the whole
equation you can figure that out get a
job mm-hmm like put it in public markets
and just wait 40 years the money will be
there if you don't have to take it out
they will as long as the company as long
as the government you put the public
market in is around like
it will be there I just people haven't
figured themselves out the stunning
amount of people in this audience that
are living their lives to appease
somebody else normally their mom or dad
and yes it's heartbreaking yes it's so
true and that's why I think most of
people is really hard for them to find
happiness even though there's a lot of
things that they can't be happy about
you can't be happy if you're not trying
to make yourself happy yeah amazing
question lady over there hi Gary
hi I'm Rita I'm the editor of
entrepreneur in India and was very glad
to read your story last month in the
magazines thank you and given what you
just said you know and I think you said
a lot about sustainability and building
a business at last yes and given the
fact that we are in the era of
disruption do you think do you think how
do you how do you ask about a start-up
to balance between disruption and
distribution because eventually I think
a lot of data give up when it comes to
distributing and finding consumers for
their product yeah I mean distribution
I am disruption are in very different
places right disruption is a thesis of
how you look at the opportunity for your
business you're either going to disrupt
yourself or somebody else is going to
disrupt you or you're starting from zero
and you're about to disrupt somebody
there's only two groups
there's the incumbents and the newcomers
right the newcomers want to disrupt
something that is an incumbent has and
that's where their opportunity is the
biggest problem with incumbents is
they're not willing to disrupt
themselves ninety nine out of a hundred
times which is why we have what we have
distribution is a totally different
thing distribution is oxygen if you
don't know how to distribute the
awareness of what you're doing nobody
knows the end so to me you know
disruption is a thesis distribution is a
currency and so the best thing in the
world is that actually from the product
or service that you're providing to be
disrupting which alludes to bringing
more value to the end consumer than what
they're offered today right which
automatically puts you in a good
situation and then you have to be
greater distribution to let
you know that there's new things that
are better than the things that you're
doing now creating a better way to clean
people's clothes is disrupting it but if
nobody here knows that to be true
through distribution it's not going to
matter
sure so so what's that advice how do you
how do you thought okay talk about both
right like like the advices be religious
blindly religious about being great at
both that's what I've done why let me
disrupt it everybody was selling wine at
their local store I wanted to ship it to
you from FedEx and UPS and DHL and I did
that in 1996 when everybody told me that
the internet was a fad and nobody would
ever buy wine on the Internet
vaynermedia is disruptive while the
biggest brands in the world want to
spend all their money on print and radio
and television and banner ads I think
that they should spend nothing on that
and should spend it on Kol Facebook
Instagram things of that nature
we're disruptive then I go and do [ __ ]
like this for distribution so that
happens sure thank you very much you're
welcome all right more questions guys
all the way there hi Gary
how are you good thank you thanks for
talking to us yes to be and the guidance
you gave us about using audio to in the
future I want to ask how we can use
media to spread the news about inclusion
social inclusion like disabilities like
what you're working on yes that's right
content okay the end like why why when a
government is going through a coup
does the army take over the media first
because the media dictates our beliefs
like you would be very sad to know how
much of what you believe to be true is
completely predicated by media either
affecting your parents grandparents or
you directly let me save you time all of
it so you need to tell stories about the
value of inclusion now
very similar to what I said to that
gentleman over there about mainland
China the biggest mistake that people
that are doing good in the world make is
they think other people give a [ __ ] and
it's a very difficult thing to say out
loud
but if you're going to trade on feelings
you're barking up the wrong tree so for
example if I joined your firm the number
one thing I would spend all my time on
is proving that it is financially viable
for inclusion and then I would sell
against money because that's how you get
quicker decisions got it so if you made
a video on Facebook and LinkedIn that
targeted all the CFO's of every company
that you wanted to do business with and
it said do you know that you can save
13% of your overhead costs with
inclusion and then went through a 1
minute 14 seconds of and it has to be
true you've got a [ __ ] concept thank
you Ranga you're talking about feelings
right that is whenever whenever we do
our marketing or selling whatever it is
you have to gain their trust do you any
work for their intention for a moment
you've got it get somebody to pay
attention yeah then you've got to get
them to feel something then they
transact the problem is most people try
to sell on fear yeah if you or
negativity or shortcomings I think a lot
of the best things to do is to sell on
positivity and optimism but it's much
harder because your product and service
has to deliver so for example insurance
everybody's got it it's super not
practical the math doesn't work out but
we all buy it because we're scared so
there's a lot of big businesses that are
built on it right I just I just find it
more interesting to trade on optimism
but there's a lot of things to trade on
entertainment escapism guys escapism is
our biggest business and all of
entertainment all of entertainment is
based on escapism
every sport in the world I think we can
all agree that Hollywood Bollywood
sports these are huge industries could
trillions of dollars all based on the
fact that we want to see people run
around and kick a ball because for those
three hours while we do that we don't
worry about how hard life is escapism is
an amazing thing to trade on cases so I
don't care what you do you just have to
do it on one of the things that get
people to care most of the marketing
here is selfish you're making the
content in your vested interest not the
audiences and that's why it doesn't work
so true I think we still have time for
one more question or two are two hi
Stephen Cooper vanilla safety you
mentioned a while ago that the secret is
happiness and I totally agree with you
and I think by finding your passion and
what you do you get happiness my
question is how do you monetize your
passion by taking your passion and
putting it into something that you can
sell okay
I know but like sometimes like for
example you you enjoy nightlife or you
enjoy and start a club start a high-end
vodka business that sells in nightlife
start an app that lets people cut the
line on the rope in nightlife the
problem is people love to talk about
passion that's great you have to put it
in a bucket that you can sell so you
have to synthesize what you love I don't
give a [ __ ] if you love fishing or
football or drinking bourbon put it into
a bucket that is a business people go
from here to here it's the middle where
you take your passion and make it
consumable that you have to do okay in
kids that makes sense yeah that's where
a lot of people Stephen and as you can
imagine I wrote a book that was all
about passion that I get bombarded
great it's your passion but unless you
put it into product form or service form
or you do such a great job talking about
your passion that you have so much
attention that you can get paid to speak
or write books you've got to put it into
something all right
this question no maybe one more hi Gary
I have a question what is your advice
for young entrepreneurs in college that
are trying to start businesses and run
them themselves quit college quit
college some problem probably if you're
actually an entrepreneur yes because I
promise you college is doing you 0 for
entrepreneurship you cannot teach
entrepreneurship in a college
environment because it is an
unbelievable reality of like you have to
navigate it to know what to do are you
collecting debt no okay good
well then haha then then you just have
to decide you know look what I would
tell you to do is prop you know what I
would to tell you if you were my brother
if you were a J I would say you got to
make a decision either you realize that
these are the last couple years that you
can really really really enjoy and not
do [ __ ] and enjoy them or you could put
all your energy into your business and
let your grades go to [ __ ] and either
get kicked out or let them push you
through the system if it's you know you
have to understand my definition of an
entrepreneur is a little bit different
than I think a lot of people's my
definition of an entrepreneur is you
can't breathe other than when you're
running your business thank you
you got it you know I was a terrible
terrible student because I couldn't
breathe I had to think about baseball
cards I had to think about comic books
and then I had when I was selling those
when I was a teenager and a kid then
when I fell in love with wine I was a
sophomore and junior in my high school
and I would sit in every class reading
wine books like just reading them like I
couldn't breathe there was nothing else
and maybe because of my love of that
entrepreneurial way entrepreneurship now
it's just popular and so it's different
and it will fail it's too hard
entrepreneurship now looks like becoming
a rapper and an athlete the difference
is those are much more black and white
if you're good enough everybody thinks
they can be one the problem is there's
very few that could be successful and
it's their life and the collateral
damage of going for it can be difficult
emotionally one thing we do not talk
enough about and one of the biggest
reasons I put stress on this
conversation is there's a lot of
underlining depression and suicide in
the inter entrepreneurial landscape yeah
and I don't want people to think they
have to become entrepreneurs right now
because it's cool only to them to fail
miserably in front of everybody and not
have the ability to swallow that loss
and that's why I talk about this not
because I'm cool and you're not it's
because it's a tough one because there's
no hiding when you're faint when your
business goes out of business
there's no you can't say it's you and
that's a tough Scarlet Letter right Wow
can we do one more is this what are my
150 yeah I think we got 150 left yeah we
can have Lynn or sneak it in
kalokhe me again Avram I would like to
thank you so much first of all I was
I've been watching your talk your videos
a lot in the morning because my mom
never supported me and I had to hear and
watch somebody that will give me this
push and I get it almost for that I
really appreciate I will tell you and I
apologize for cutting you off
I was so supported by my mom to be an
entrepreneur and I want to remind people
and this is a great crowd to understand
me I was an immigrant if you're an
immigrant or you come from immigrant
parents education is the way out every
Russian Jewish boy and girl that came to
the Soviet Union with my parents was
getting straight A's on their way to
Harvard I was getting straight apps this
also for my mom to have the self-esteem
to not care what the other parents
thought to let me do my thing is was
such a gift that I now produce content
on a daily basis because I feel guilty
that I had it so good
and I want to provide that for you guys
that is why I do it
that's amazing go ahead thank you and I
just want to make it one thing clear and
my mom loves me angry yes I bet you just
hate me seeing seeing me failing
universe it was written her fear about
when I was invited to give a speech as a
first Turkish person in China its
headaches and then she start to share
the we go before everyone of course now
that she pushes me you should do it you
were not my mom but um there is one
section that is eating my heart out and
I really want to hear your opinion so
yesterday I got a comment from one of
the one of I'm so sorry yesterday I got
a comment from one of the people
attending to this conference about my
three chart up yeah oh yeah my startup
so I'm miss honorifics partners we
talked before but as I said we started
with excess but it grew to returnees
local people sea turtles that been
abroad but came back and any group to
neighboring and local vision and global
businesses but now the expats is a
mindset but the person told me to quit
using experts but then it's just the
journey what do you think about it
changing starting with one name and then
throughout the whole journey the whole
thing changes evolution of course do you
think that it's going to change the name
of the company or so there's two things
that run through my mind one I think it
before we even get to that part because
that's the easy part the first part is
how much do you think about driving the
business in the way that you think about
it versus other people that you respect
and what their opinions are is very
important number two it just depends on
how good of a brand name you have it
seems that your business is small enough
and young enough that it doesn't matter
if you change your name now but there
was one thing um so we got the
partnership with shangri-la and then the
peach person in that hotel at one time
he said so you're out you're in X but
what if you leave I'm like well I'm not
and another director in the hotel so
that you can it's your identity and I I
don't say it that person said it so
Michael whoa-ho wall yeah strong but yes
we're still small in that case yeah I
mean I'll be very honest with you this
is a non-issue one way or the other
genuinely genuinely I believe that
whatever you decide to do it's going to
be completely relevant to the outcome of
the business okay thank you so much
you're welcome I appreciate that's
amazing
okay okay the time is up guys thank you
so much for being here thank you so much
Gary Vee I'm Cheryl Mariela buy back
their fee on the next
you